ce jeune homme est une victime des
attentats de novembre 2015 il
travaillait dans l'un des établissements
visés par les terroristes
cet homme d'origine algérienne souhaite
rester anonyme nous l'appellerons
anthony il y à peu il a demandé un
renouvellement de son titre de séjour
comme chaque année il se l'est vu
refuser est désormais sous le coup d'une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français
une eau du tf le jeune homme est dévasté
je n'arrive plus à me concentrer je me
stresse là franchement ce n'est ce n'est
pas facile je n'arrive pas à comprendre
je travaille depuis
des années quand même en france je suis
arrivé à l'âge de 17 ans donc je voyage
et pas mal d'endroits en france donc
j'aime bien la france j'ai pas mal
d'amis français et moi je me dis que ma
vie est ici en france la vie d'anthony a
basculé le jour des attentats en voyant
les terroristes tirent et il est parti
se cacher avec d'autres dans les
toilettes du bar dans lequel il
travaille est surmonté le traumatisme
fut difficile après ce que j'ai vécu
c'est trop dur j'étais traumatisée
j'arrive plus à sortir le soir pendant
pendant des mois et des mois et donc
j'étais suivie par des psys par des
médecins
parfois quand j'entends des trucs du
bruit en terrasse ça fait flipper ça me
fait peur je suis resté toujours
travaillé dans le même établissement et
ce n'était pas facile
tous mes anciens collègues ils ont tous
partis sauf moi anthony a fini par être
embauchés en cdi puis s'est marié avec
une française en 2016 il satisfaisait
donc aux critères pour rester en france
mais sa séparation l'a brutalement
privés de justificatifs mais au vu du
dossier
son avocat maître henri braun s'indigne
de cette décision
dans ces circonstances le fait que la
préfecture de police et pu imaginer lui
délivrer une obligation qui était le
territoire à sortir cette obligation
d'une interdiction de retour sur le
territoire d'une durée de trois ans ce
qui l'empêchent defacto d'assister au
procès des attentats qui doit s'ouvrir
le 8 septembre et qui est prévu pour
durer jusqu'en mars 2022 me paraît
absolument incompréhensible anthony
investi dans une association de victimes
attendaient beaucoup du procès
ça fait mal très mal et
j'aimerais bien quand même assister à ce
procès parce que je suis je suis je suis
victime ce soir là j'ai failli mourir m
brown va déposer un recours et si
nécessaire a référé se demande
évidemment qu'ils soient régularisés
mais aussi qu'ils soient naturalisé la
foulée parce qu'il ne mérite ce parce
que la france c'est son pays parce
qu'ils aiment ce pays qui l'a adopté et
également je voudrais qu'une enquête
administrative soit diligentée afin de
comprendre comment une telle aberration
a pu avoir lieu et qui éventuellement
des sanctions soient prononcées contre
les agents qui ont se sont permis de
prendre une décision aussi inacceptable
frédérique calandra la déléguée
interministérielle à l'aide aux victimes
a déclaré qu'une autorisation
exceptionnelle de séjour il sera délivré
pour assister au procès si d'ici là sa
situation n'a pas été régularisée
marlène schiappa ministre délégué auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur a de son côté
souhaité qu'une solution soit trouvée et
que la demande d'anthony soit examinée